yeah they're big news big news here
katanji brown jackson is now on the
supreme court that pass
when it was announced in the senate all
the republicans headed for the exits
really
nice huh
looked like one of those oldies concerts
when the band says are we going to play
some songs from our new album
i mean
come on guys
the only one who i saw was stated and
applaud was mitt romney mitt romney i
got to say
for a cult the mormons are very polite
you know
but
i mean this is the new thing with the
republican party is they call anybody
who they don't like a pedophile marjorie
taylor green called mitt romney
because he voted for
the new supreme court just called
and the other two republicans who voted
for pedophiles should their pro pro pedo
mitt romney is pro-pedophile would
you
would you think for a second about
leaving your kid with mitt romney for an
hour
seriously
he might baptize them
but not anything
although
the mormons i gotta say their big
college is called bring them young i
don't know about
i don't know
but this is
this is
this is the new talking point uh in
magnation that you know don't say gay
and grooming that's their big new word a
grooming everybody's grooming
and if you've ever seen a trump rally
one thing these people will not stand
for is grooming
we did
but
no this is i i
i think this is all coming from q anon
right i mean
i'm going to ask the panel maybe they
know
uh well i don't mean personally i'm just
being but i think it is because q and on
were the ones who were talking about
remember their democrats eat babies i
mean this eat they eat babies and they
have sex with children first of all
how does that work how could you do both
if you're eating babies
aren't you devouring your future dating
pool
you